you guys have all heard the new
McDonald's slogan I'm loving it with
camp according to a recent note from
Janney Capital Markets the fast-food
giant will soon enter a scale as one of
its ingredients the no ads possibilities
include tale for you some salads or
perhaps a kale smoothie and we're
generally McDonald's clearly aims to
raise consumers perceptions of the
quality of its food all right so I eat a
ton of kale I do a kale shake every
morning kale Caesar salads I love the
kale kale and McDonald's something
doesn't seem quite right what because
it's healthy yeah healthy McDonald's
what's going on here they must be up to
no good right I mean hey if it's gonna
get people to eat healthier than I'm all
for it ya know this is like yet another
like health food that they can just
paint into something unhealthy like
really took yogurt and we made it
unhealthy we took vegetables and apple
slices and made them unhealthy now we're
going to take que l'on head on yes are
they gonna fry kale like that's where
this is all going right because don't
people go isn't the whole point of going
to mcdonald's not for health like
they're trying to trick us into thinking
you're gonna walk out of there feeling
better but that's not the point of
mcdonalds right at the finding that its
food so the point of it is to eat you
know so if we could get people to do
that in a healthier way then I don't
think that's such a bad thing but I
don't think a little bit of kale on Big
Mac is gonna make a big difference yeah
I mean their major but they're they're
pulling some major double standard here
because I don't know if you remember a
little while back they literally came
out and had it juicy burger and made a
statement you can't get this kind of
juice from soy or quinoa and this isn't
kayla creature lift weights Kurt kale
sells really well this is actually a
delicious quinoa burger drizzled in a
like a nice fresh kale South like yeah
with them just to clarify were saying
literally that was like a month ago they
were mocking kale and then the kale
people must have got to the right and
now they're they're pro kale so we
should you want to give McDonald's
credit I can see what's going on here
right you are there because I'm trying
to give them credit I'm just saying if
that you know I'm sure it's a marketing
ploy oh yes but at the same time it's a
good one you know it's
it's gonna be good for people and I mean
I know that they were very hypocritical
because I did see that commercial yeah
they were just like hey you this is
obviously not because it's just big and
fat and greasy yeah unhealthy food yay
but now they're starting to put it in
there and I'm not gonna really complain
because it's like kind of like in my
mind somebody saying I'm not gonna ever
donate to charity now I am no you can't
because you said you were going to it's
like okay I'm right let that go so I
know we're in LA here I've had you guys
on the show a million times we do a lot
about food and people eating healthier
and trying to source food locally and
all that stuff but there is a place for
McDonald's and this kind of stuff I do
you ever get that craving like suddenly
you're like I've got to eat something
from economy seeing heart McDonald's or
Burger usually had several cocktails
yeah so that's what it for you it's like
the drunken yeah like if I'm drunk like
late at night um which never happens by
the way um you know sometimes I like
that incredibly shiny bun like I like to
be able to see my self reflection in the
fish fillet but like that's what I like
yeah yeah do you ever feel it coming out
of you that's what I eat it very rarely
now maybe like once every three months
McDonald's I when I do it I can actually
feel it i think i authorize I never feel
it coming out of me life yeah just I
think it's still in there so yeah how
often do you go to the guilty route I I
Dommy it's hard for me cuz I'm a
vegetarian so a lot of fun I not know
you were a vegetarian or all this time I
don't know a lot of fast food places
aren't an option yeah so what is it well
I guess you could go to like in and out
they do like you get like a bun with
some letters than that the girls yeah
yeah but so you can't so you do nothing
I guess you could do it right I'm not
really any better shake shake sauce you
want a kale shake from ago I don't know
if I want a kale shake from mcdon like
today I don't I'm sure them like
actually blending it and with the ice
cream ice cream there you go all right
what do you guys think Cal mcdonalds is
it a big marketing ploy they actually
make us healthier let us know in the
comments right down below